what is happening there citizens the
reject Nation we are going to watch him
screen Crush today black panther wakanda
forever plot holes questions answered
and Ryanair is going to go out of his
way to do it join by my co-host today
John how are you I am I'm well I'm
excited to fill in some plot holes I
came out with gripes that's right we are
nothing but nitpicks over here
Nancy's hey guys I was on uh the screen
Crush over the weekend actually I was
part of the Black Panther wakanda
forever review you guys should go check
that out defended this movie that's what
it ended up turning into but yeah leave
a like it'd be very much appreciated
let's get to it
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hey there welcome back to screen Crush
I'm Ryan Airy and hello Ryan black
panther wakanda forever specifically all
the little things that didn't quite make
sense in the movie now we asked all of
you to send us your plot holes on our
community page and on my Twitter and
some of you had great questions others
of you just need to watch the movie and
some of you are just bad people but now
let the fun begin let's start with where
the movie started at the funeral at your
ugly clone asked why didn't a single
Avenger attend the funeral not even his
best friend Clint Barton who he met at
the airport that one time
I'm glad I don't care now this is a
pretty good point and a few of you also
asked why Bucky was not there since he
had such a strong connection to wakanda
well wakanda was an isolationist country
for thousands of years with their own
sacred rituals they should open
themselves up to the world it could be
they believe that it will content
funeral is the sacred ritual that sends
a person off to the realm of the dead
and Ryan coogler even said that the
funeral is actually a celebration and in
the movie they actually sing thanks for
the gift of t'challa so an outsider's
worldly Viewpoint might have tarnished a
ceremony in some way also maybe there
was another service for Outsiders maybe
there were Avengers at the funeral but
we just didn't see them on camera but I
doubt it the only Avenger that t'challa
actually seemed close to was Steve
Rogers and now he's on the moon who are
you Captain America black Captain
America was on the moon there's also
Bucky but remember he's not on good
terms with his old friends in wakanda
but mostly there were no Avengers at the
funeral
to help out later in the movie and it
would have taken the focus off the
wakandans this got brought up in our
live stream and my main reasoning for
why is it I think just from the fact
that this movie was so focused on its
emotional context ultimately feel like
any appearance from any Avenger would
have just distracted from the main
emotion at heart I mean unless you're
one of the viewers who was watching this
really sad opening and realize it's so
tragic were the Avengers they are
callous uncaring people distracting me
he helped us so many times that they
don't care I think it's a great point
that he brings up that maybe there could
be a different opportunity for them to
to grieve but moreover I think you're
absolutely right it's like any one face
or presence I feel like it's important
to keep the aura and the spirit of this
movie inside of wakanda Brandon red asks
why the queen questions nakia's absence
from the funeral when she actually knew
the reason that she she wasn't there
spoiler alert she knew that t'challa and
Nakia had a son so she did not approve
of her grandchild not being brought to
wakanda for his dad's funeral I mean the
answer seems pretty obvious to me we
also had a lot of questions about
t'challa Junior Namor and teleconda I'm
going to talk about in just a bit first
all of you had lots of questions about
Shorey when Ramona arrives home from the
U.N she tells shuri how uncomfortable
the AI makes her and talks about how
she's afraid of a rogue AI wiping Henry
H on Twitter asked why Sherry just
dismissed this Rogue AI question when
Ultron nearly destroyed the world just a
few years earlier and not for nothing
that event made the wakandan step from
the shadows and sign the sokovia Accords
yes well because shuri is so brilliant
she would have understood how Ultron
came to be Ultron is not an ordinary AI
he was given sentience by the Mind Stone
and the mind Stone no longer exists so
that means that an AI would no longer be
a threat all of the AIS that we have
seen in the MCU are all very great
points if I were her I wouldn't be
disappointed at all thanks Karen as
always a great pleasure watching you
work what do I look like uh I don't know
I've been picturing a redhead you must
be thinking of someone else that's
actually really saw a way to explain
because yeah every time I watch the
movie I have thought like what about
Ultra yeah what about Ultra maybe it was
a fault on the screenwriters who are
just not bothering to remember Ultron
but yeah especially with the visuals you
back up with here
solid points solid points all around no
magic to put those strings on you square
bear77 asked why shuri was trying to
make another heart-shaped herb to save
him from this illness when he already
had the heart-shaped Urban as blood I
kind of think this one's
self-explanatory the herb has healing
properties concentrated healing
properties kind of like the super
soldier serum remember the serum also
did cure Steve's asthma see the herb and
t'challa system was not strong enough to
cure his illness but sure he could have
used another herb to create a potent
medicine that would have fixed him we
also had a lot of you questioning
shuri's skills as a black panther Mott
awesome says sure he can't fight tonight
here we go yeah there's more agile and
acrobatic than t'challa and Daredevil
combined during the final fight now for
one thing I love how she moved during
this fight she actually moved more like
a cat than the other black panthers that
we've seen and it's more reflective
before fighting style sure he isn't the
strongest t'challa or his killmonger but
she is lighter and faster now as for how
she learned how to fight come on guys
there's a movie she drops off Ross then
she goes to fight killmonger but on the
way she stopped Ops to put on her
ceremonial combat face paint you don't
have ceremonial combat face paint unless
you've been trained to fight that's what
I thought too I feel like that was a
it's been a big question on people's
minds but I'm like I imagine if you're
part of the Warrior Camp at all even
though she was leaning into her
strengths in the first movie with
Weaponry that she probably has some type
of combat training which is only just
further enhanced by having the Black
Panther a skill set now imbued
throughout her whole system you know
yeah this seems like a place where you
would grow up just knowing how to take
care of yourself in a fight and if you
look at her and Ramona on the shore
there when Namor shows up they're both
ready to go like you know they have to
have a baseline especially if they're
royalty you would imagine yeah I never
really found much of a plot hole but a
lot of people didn't question it in this
movie we learned that t'challa was a
scientist as well as a warrior and the
reverse is true for sure sure he learned
how to fight but she focused more on her
lab work the opposite of how t'challa
chose to live his life also guys she
fought killmonger she fought corvus
Glade she fought in the final battle and
end game she fought Thanos have you ever
fought Thanos I have not so there
how did shuri learn how to fight and how
was she able to defeat no more a
die-hard warrior who's been around for
centuries well Tony she defeated Neymar
by trapping him in a ship yeah
for that she would not have stood a
chance and a couple people mentioned
that shuri has a gaping hole in her
stomach at the end of the movie that
should have killed her I'll let her
explain it bullet wounds don't just
magic magical overnight
they do here even when Ross was first
shot at the childish of the Komodo bead
in the hole to stabilize him and I'm
sure that Sherry just did the same for
herself and we also had lots of Riri
Williams and rightly so weary is one of
the few elements of the movie that you
could remove and the plot wouldn't even
suffer that much but she did help shuri
out of her grief by giving her a friend
who was Untouched by the tragedy of
t'challa's death Sasha's space asks how
was Rory able to create a location
device for vibranium if she had never
seen it wouldn't she need at least a
small sample of it to create that sort
of machine how can you locate something
you've never seen or touched yeah like
I've never seen a girl well I don't
think that she would have needed to have
seen her touched by Girl Detective if
she knew the molecular structure of
vibranium then she would be able to
craft a formula and a device that in
theory could attract metal remember her
professor dismissed the idea and then
sold the plans to the government himself
siriri was pleasantly surprised to hear
that it even worked grubitron three yeah
it was so intent on killing Riri she
already built the machine the government
already has and knows how to make the
tech killing her would accomplish
nothing so I believe they say in the
movie that this machine is their only
one and that they didn't yes like Belle
says that yeah the professor didn't sell
the plans to the machine he sold the
actual machine it's also likely that the
government couldn't reverse engineer the
machine because it was cobbled together
from so many parts that weary found kind
of like how Richard Pryor designed a
supercomputer and cigarette packages in
Superman 3. kind of like that yes now I
know that explanation is Justice for
Superman 3. what they say in the movie I
think that they definitely could have if
you have a whole team of scientists I
think you could have reverse engine
you're just so incompetent in this world
and I mean she's not so
astronomically brilliant it would take a
long time but they could do it I know
that Tony Stark built the Iron Man so
with a box of scraps like I I get that
he also has way more years of experience
and had help from Yin send in that movie
here I just feel like they would be able
to go oh it's like this week I feel like
they could have reverse engineering well
yeah she's got access to like Stark Tech
schematics and stuff like that alien
Tech exists on earth like people can
Bridge the gaps yeah at ELO KS the U.S
aren't going to kidnap and force
Williams to build another the moment she
arrives home they might that might be
what the Iron Heart show is about when
Rarity leaves wakanda sure he said if
she gets better her problems with the
police but this is probably just talking
about the agents that were pursuing
shuri and Okoye now I think a lot of
this is going to play out in a later
movie with the government trying to
destabilize wakanda and like tricking
Riri into helping them couldn't have
worked better if I planned it myself
oh well maybe I did so peace even says
not really a plot hole but a question
who was the professor that sold the
machine in the first place of the CIA
that seems like who everyone really
should have been going after Riri even
said that she just made the machine to
prove them wrong and said that they must
have sold it they could have added a
name drop as the second post-credits
scene I'm just saying I don't care I
don't care who the professor was some
jerk one if he was worth naming then he
would have been the one who invented the
detector it was who Peter Parker talked
to certainly drops his quest to capture
weary after all the reason he approached
Ramona and Sherry to begin with was to
force them to bring weary to him at
least that's what he told them what no
more actually one was for wakanda to
acknowledge the power of talocon once
they did that then the wakandans would
want to see him as an ally and then they
can invade the surface world together
the more made that pretty clear
someone who was harmless and who could
potentially help his people he even
tells shuri that after they're done with
the surface World Riri can go home that
damn kez asks why didn't the more just
kidnap and kill Riri when he sent the
water in the throne room again because
he didn't actually care about Riri he
just didn't want her to make a vibranium
detector for the government once she she
was in wakanda he knew that she would be
safe from the USA so he didn't care also
and this is by the way far more likely
Riri was unconscious when nemour told
shuri to bury her dead so nemour likely
thought that he killed both her and
Ramona but remember his goal was to
force wakanda into being an ally and he
would have let Riri live if that was the
cost of doing business a few people
asked what Ramona was going to tell
shuri about t'challa before she died
I have a question why were there so many
women in this movie I have a question
why do you care these are characters
that have been built up over several
movies who had real emotional stakes and
your first thought is where's the boys
yeah you're right I'm sorry and now we
have all grown emotionally yeah high
five for maturity I don't think they
addressed who was ruined wakanda during
the in-game time skip more of a minor
issue but one I know that most fans are
curious about look I'm pretty sure it
was Ramona but you're right they don't
mention it she was definitely alive
during the blip because she references
Nakia being gone for six years and she
would only say that if she were around
for those six years yeah we could fill
in the gap
Thanos or his minions to cross the sea
to enter wakanda and take the Mind Stone
from Vision how is it possible that
nemour and Friends managed to arrive in
wakanda without problems doesn't the
wakanda barrier go underwater okay
that's a couple questions and they're
both really good Sanders and his minions
didn't use water to arrive in wakanda
for a couple of reasons one they can't
breathe underwater and probably aren't
used to doing amphibious assaults
they're from space two they're arrogant
and would have rolled over every single
world they'd ever encountered they would
have assumed that a little mud ball like
Earth would not have been able to mount
a defense against them not a great plan
as for the wakandan barrier going
underwater when Ramona ship passes
through the shield early in the movie it
does look like the gate pierces the
water but we also see these guards have
to hit a particular water drum to open
it my guess is the talicans swam through
some sort of underground Waterway and
then disabled The Shield after all we do
see groundswells of water erupting
throughout the Golden City showing that
they did have command of the city's
water supply it's also possible that
maybe like Andy Dufresne they crawled
through the sewers to come out clean on
the other side once they had
circumvented the barrier a couple of
their forces did is able to Shield using
this water drum and then the main Force
could sneak in through the river well
yeah I mean to me I didn't even question
that at all just like they clearly owned
the water yeah and the gun is surrounded
by water everywhere that of course they
could just find a way around and I could
be mistaken but I feel like at one point
one of the teleconils says something
about the depths or maybe it's nemour
says something about the depths of like
how deep they had to swim to like get in
here or something like that yeah or
maybe I don't know maybe there's a water
pocket that they can go in and tunnel up
yeah I didn't really it's like you said
they're they're the the King of Queens
is the underwater like they can get
around if they happen they can go as
deep as they need to to go under
anything yeah and they you have like
Sonic you know ethereal power so they
could probably yeah create some kind of
frequency and open up one of those
hexagons now a few of you asked why they
couldn't recast t'challa and you know I
was back and forth on this because for
me t'challa is a concept he's a comic
book character that will live forever
but in practice in the movies that isn't
true he is Chadwick Boseman at least for
now now if Bozeman would have left the
role because of a contract dispute then
fine he would have been recast but the
way he passed and so suddenly and so
young if you had cast another actor
there just would have been endless
comparisons
also I happen to know that there is a
little t'challa on the way so we'll have
a black panther named t'challa at some
point in the future but more on him
later yeah and I also just feel like it
probably wouldn't have been as much of a
genuine experience for everyone involved
with making the film actors and crew but
mainly like the actors especially
probably I can see it coming out more
strained honestly yeah everyone having
to like corral together as if this just
didn't happen I think that regardless it
would have been an endless comparison
that version sounds more of a
distraction than 100 because anything
short of like a breathtakingly great
performance is still not going to skip
the conversation but like you know
anything short of perfection was gonna
get compared and probably dogged on
anyway and that's like a thankless job
for any actor to jump into it's not like
with Doctor Who where you're like it's a
new doctor it's a noob and part of it is
that they're a new person like you
wouldn't be acknowledging that this
person's new they'd have to continue to
be to create a whole new weird Ed Norton
Mark ruffalo's situation for them to
have to deal with but more painful and I
feel like we came out with a movie
that's really unique in the end too yeah
and wakanda had their backs against the
wall the whole movie yeah it's called
good storytelling if the wakandans would
have won all the time then it would have
been boring like House of Cards David
Riley said the biggest thing though is
the title when the movie ended it didn't
go on forever I felt lied to this is the
Val Kilmer Batman movie All Over Again
David you're not allowed to make
comments anymore let's go sit down
what's funny is Nate Moore actually came
out recently the producer and said that
they wanted to reserve the title wakanda
forever for their third film because
they thought it would just be more
fitting yeah but now that you brought
Batman Forever I would have been like
well that would just be like Batman
Forever
yeah that's good it was meant to be
let's move on to all the questions we
had about the telecons call taishan asks
so you mean to tell me that the telecons
from the jump have an audible hypnotic
device that works on all who first hear
it but the movie isn't automatically
over yet and all it takes is for someone
to shake it and disrupt it for them to
never use it again and to just choose to
start actually using close fighting
instead okay it was a hard one to read
first of all they don't have an audible
hypnotic device they have the power to
sing and attract people into the sea I
actually really love this new power of
theirs because it ties into mythology of
the sirens Sirens
but this is a power they cannot use all
the time because they can't breathe
above water for very long and you're
right in the end they do get hit with
wakandan Sonic cannons that disrupt
their abilities and the wakandans came
into this last fight prepared when the
talocons attacked wakanda IO put a Sonic
dampener in her ear which I'm sure that
first started using it when they showed
up in the final battle so the hypnotic
sonic power would not have been
effective also the [ __ ] that they're on
is very high up meaning that the siren
sounds probably aren't as strong and
like I said they don't use their power
when they're fighting in close quarters
because they wouldn't be able to breathe
and they would be vulnerable it's also
possible that using the power is
directly tied to them being within the
ocean maybe the Canon's a different
frequency David Edwin colestone says
blew out of water and normal neutral
skin tones in the deep ocean how I
understand it's a suspended reality but
I think I needed more on the World
building of talocon what is wrong with
you
why are you blue all right so I'm glad
you noticed this I noticed it too but
because I'm a little bit colorblind I
just assumed it was me but a couple of
users have also had good responses to
this clouded Sky 88 says doesn't that
have to do with the reflection of light
on the surfaces and the angle defines
the color of light so because the light
doesn't break through it's blue
underwater now it is true that objects
appear to be different colors when
they're viewed in different environments
and different types of light it's that
blue and gold dress thing all over again
but collected disconnect has an even
better explanation don't humans turn
blue and purple when they're suffocating
this reminded me of Luca the Disney
movie obviously their skin reacts to
oxygen and the sun that's why he made an
artificial one under the sea for his
people now that's a better explanation I
think something about their physiology
is different when they are not
underwater symbolically it's also a nice
touch when they're home they're just
people but when they're on the surface
World they are blue they are the other
see blue skin was also used by the
artist siona Benjamin to illustrate a
form of otherness that she felt in her
own life as an Indian Jew Living in
America Michael Walton says
about wearing a suit because the
pressure will crush her bones and yet
she escapes the waterplace on the back
of an underwater sub with no suit
because my friend she needed the suit to
go down Into the Depths and see the
actual city of telecon she was much
closer to the surface than a Cenote when
she left with Nakia and this one says so
Nakia could just so conveniently not
only know exactly where the underwater
telecon pod would be whenever she jumped
into the ocean it was a wakandan
underwater she knew where it was because
guys
she brought them so she brought her own
pod and this person also asked how she
was able to sneak past we don't need a
pause he's a war dog a spy and a badass
another person asked the blues were
stabbed and sliced to death on the
bridge fight but got up and jumped back
in the water early in the movie but the
one blue gets shot and dies no
explanation I suppose I mean look this
one took a close range hit from a
wakandan blaster like right in the lung
the telecons on the bridge did not get
hit in as critical a spot or with his
deadly of a weapon I don't think he need
an explanation for this like it's all in
the movie then why didn't they have
those weapons on the finale fight that's
a good thing my mind went too
and also that spear is made of vibranium
which is pretty damn powerful on the
bridge there and Nokia has that weapon
all of them should have had that weapon
and just Bam Bam Bam [ __ ] Alpha talking
says italicons seemed to heal from
nearly every death early in the film
only to drop like flies in the
obligatory MCU group battle at the end
why for nothing the wakandans were
pretty much better prepared to fight
than them they fought in their Turf but
for another they kicked the crap out of
the wakandans and then had them covered
when they called off the war now we also
had a few questions about the final
fight like why the wakandans fought the
telecons on a boat instead of in the
Jabari mountains like okay why would the
talocons even attack them and the Jabar
yeah
be a horrible disadvantage so of course
they chose a boat that was still high
above the water this drew the Mur people
out but it also forced them to scale the
side of a ship leaving them vulnerable
the telecons had no reason whatsoever to
chase the wakandans all the way up a
mountain they could have never lured
them there so they couldn't have set the
trap for no more now a lot of people
also thought how it was messed up how
they killed like 90 percent of all
conscious forces but then they just
declare a truce all right well look
first of all we don't know that they
killed 90 of their forces just the
forces on the boat I'm sure they left
their home country very well defended
and second of all it's not like either
wanted this fight they wanted peace the
entire time and also wakanda is a nation
of Warriors who accept that people die
in combat
ending in the history I mean look how
fast they got over their massive Civil
War and somebody else asks why would
nemour care about a long-term War if
they just killed most of okana's elite
forces because brother it's still
wakanda they still have Tech and more
armies and probably allies all over the
surface World a lot of people mentioned
that no one in the movie ever mentions
or makes reference to a giant ass
Celestial sticking out of the ocean yeah
no one ever does yes fair in the
eternals there is a public explanation
for tiamat's existence the appearance of
an enormous Stone figure in the Indian
Ocean has left more questions than
answers for authorities people don't
realize that it's a space god they think
that it's just a rock formation that
looks like a space God and this was also
acknowledged in She-Hulk in a news
article also telecon is located just off
the coast of Mexico and Tiamat rose out
of the sea in the Indian Ocean unlike in
the comics no more doesn't claim to rule
over the entire ocean just this one city
although you know what they have been
around for hundreds of years so some of
them might have splintered off and
founded colonies all over the planet oh
totally yeah I mean doesn't Neymar
there's some line in there about how he
won't they don't he won't move again or
something like that yeah like so this is
not the first spot and the only spot
talocan is remaining it sounds like
they've migrated before you would think
unless he just met down from the beach
but it it certainly felt like there was
history there that we maybe haven't seen
yet there were lots of questions about
Namor yeah like why do they have to
change him so much from the comics I
don't know go ask your mom
they had to change no more for one thing
because Aquaman came out just four years
ago and another king of Atlantis would
have seemed like just a repeat of that
same concept instead they changed him in
a way that perfectly fit the story that
Ryan coogler wanted to tell a hireable
Drew says how did Amor get into wakanda
how did the whales get into wakanda why
did the queen know about baby how did
the whales get to bust well I'm pretty
sure she knew about shuri but as for the
queen not knowing about the baby look
shuri was blipped and ramonda wasn't so
ramonda would have been around when
Nakia gave birth now ask for your other
question we talked earlier about how the
telecoms could have gotten into wakanda
but even if they swam to the sewers we
do see the whales carrying them through
fresh water into the river well it could
be that the shield does not extend
underwater or that they disable the
shield by using water concussion
grenades to destroy the controls as for
the whale Believe It or Not orca whales
have been seen in freshwater rivers all
around the world such as the Thames the
ride and one whale even swam up the
river Tay in Dundee Scotland hell Steve
even mentioned seeing whales and the
Hudson no I saw a pot of whales when I
was coming over the bridge and the
Hudson fewer ships cleaner water most
whales can survive in fresh water for
limited times because as mammals they
actually breathe air on the surface but
this is the reason why the telecons
didn't bring sharks sharks could not
survive in fresh water or remember the
telecons can control water no more has
to activate the jet stream that takes
shuri to the telecon capital and when
the wakandans first attack we see water
bursting through a wall that could have
been some sort of dam so it's possible
that they just pushed all the
underground water under wakanda upwards
which broke through their barriers a lot
of people asked why to more than that
end game well for one thing he had no
idea what the hell was going on half of
Telecom disappears hell he might have
even disappeared why would he have gone
to the surface to fight in a battle with
people he had no idea existed Joe
expansion asks how did Neymar get all
the political updates off the surface he
knew a lot about recent events he did
know a lot about recent events
especially those concerning wakanda the
other nation in the world that has
vibranium remember we get Wi-Fi here
surface world who no more has had
contact with Nakia even questions one of
them I think it's likely that more does
visit the surface disguised and learns
about potential threats to his people
and after wakanda revealed itself to be
another powerful civilization with a
large store of vibranium he would have
started paying very close attention to
the outside world he does also seem to
have some type of super hearing like
when he says he overhears shuri speaking
about burning the world yeah he must
have been underwater at that point yeah
yeah absolutely so he could probably
just lurk and not even have to talk to
anybody yeah he just happened to be
around a television that was playing the
news while he was in the water come up
by a TV your local newsstand and you got
everything you need la-284 asks not
really a plot hole but why doesn't
nemour wear a Camelbak or bring a water
bottle or something his Kryptonite was
basically a freaking dehumidifier all
right look I don't think Namor had any
idea this was his weakness this was his
first time fighting the surface World in
hundreds of years so he always
approached them on his terms and he's of
Both Worlds explained that they
basically gave him the same weakness as
Aquaman in the comics that he just
always needs to be near the ocean
Melissa D asks how his hair dries out so
quickly well look he was inside of a
giant hair dryer and also his skin dries
out fast that's why he needs to be near
water so I assume that his hair dries
that fast as well Crystal loved the city
asks I think I saw that one of Neymar's
Rings was very important questions no
consequences or repercussions from that
or was it just some of the feathers got
ripped off and not the whole thing is
banded Deputy into the movie so I do
think that it grows back and remember
this broken wing is what prevented him
from flying away from shuri when she had
him pinned down okay here's another one
no more gives away a sacred relic of
telecon to a total stranger and that
same Relic ultimately is the key to
restoring their rival's greatest
protector alright so for one thing he
had no idea that shuri could use the
fibers of the bracelet to synthesize the
heart-shaped herb and make herself the
Black Panther the telecons don't have
that kind of advanced Tech that
wakandans do so nemour could have never
dreamed that would happen but for
another thing this was part of nemour's
plan he did not want to invade wakanda
if he did want to take over wakanda he
just would have finished the job he
wanted to show wakanda and he was strong
and make it them an ally but he also
gave shuri this gift as a diplomatic
measure to make sure that she would find
a way to sympathize with his people and
it worked the movie ends with Sherry
seeing the telecoms as just like the
wakandans and with no more recognizing
his mother's own innocence and shuri
yeah I think that was like I think
especially in terms of the emotional
symbolic meaning that Ryan was just
pointing out like when he is dying and
after shuri sees Angela Bassett in the
ancestral plane he looks up and sees his
mom I feel like that was probably always
a subconscious Association seeing the
likeness of his mom or the Innocents or
whatever it may be within within her as
well so I feel like that's why I also
felt he could bargain with her whereas
you know Ramona doesn't quite have that
type of
welcoming yeah yeah it's like it makes
sense as a gesture and it makes sense
thematically Trinity's dad asks not a
plot hole but the telecon headdress with
the feathers that are waterproof and
stay pristine even after coming out of
the water so are these feathers from
what bird or are they feathers at all
all right look Trinity's Dad this is
really nitpicking the more probably goes
to the surface kills a bird plucks the
feathers and then I would imagine hands
those feathers off to some Artisans who
can make his crown they probably pick
birds that are laminate the feathers
partially aquatic so the feathers can
stand up to the salt water when the salt
water does start to erode those feathers
he goes back to the surface to get
another bird I actually really hope
there is a very specific question no
more doing all of this so you can get a
sense for how boring it would have been
to see this play out in the movie not
Mephisto says no bubbles when no more
speaks underwater nope because he
breathes through his skin like
amphibians and finally we had quite a
few questions about the ending number
one who's Kink look I don't think that
in Baku challenging at the end was a gag
I think he literally wants the throne
but he and sure he became close friends
yes like I said in our ending explained
video I think he is taking the throne
though at her request so she can focus
on being black panther because she is
not yet Ready To Rule wakanda now this
could cause political problems in the
future which I'm going to talk about in
another video really soon this week a
lot of people also had questions about
t'challa Jr like why they wanted him
raised away from wakanda well can
consider the timeline here if t'challa
and Nakia hooked up and had the baby
within a year the first movie then this
is right after a civil war ripped the
country in two it's also a very
vulnerable time for their Nation as they
have revealed themselves to the world so
the son of a king the heir to the throne
could be exploited by other political
factions like killmonger supporters they
could have say assassinated t'challa and
then kept the boy but that's a
pessimistic view of things another way
of looking at it is that the kid was
going to be a bridge to the outside
world Nakia and t'challa wanted wakanda
to understand the outside world so they
could play somebody with an outsider's
viewpoint on the throne also you know
it's a lot like Harry Potter the kid
would be so famous in his own world so
to keep him level-headed they raise him
in more humble surroundings where he's
not famous I actually haven't heard that
yet that's a great reasoning yeah I mean
I like the Harry Potter and you're a
wizard the whole idea of where it ended
off of Black Panther once that way you
have both a respect and reverence for
the outside world as opposed to viewing
it as a thing you gotta isolate yourself
from which is obviously something
wakanda still struggles with welcoming
in so if you have that kind of person
there you would who who eventually does
come back to wakanda they would be able
to help bridge a gap yeah and also
coming from a place like Haiti which has
had you know pretty significant
traumatic you know events happen to it
in recent years you know this would be
somebody who not only knows a more
normal way of life but also like the
true needs of people out there and
people not very much unlike the people
of wakanda makes a lot of sense yeah
namdo says and your ending explained
video you talked about time dilation and
bringing someone to space to make them
age faster I think they grow slower not
faster think of Pixar's Buzz Lightyear
movie alright so in our end explained
video I mentioned how they could age up
Prince t'challa by sending him into
space where time would pass faster and
he would return in his teens or
something like that so look time dilated
already go to space gravity in the
theory of relativity basically the
higher planets Gravity the slower time
passes like an Interstellar it's time
the gravity on that planet will slow our
clock compared to Earth's
drastically but it can work in the
reverse way if he went to a planet with
lighter gravity that would also kind of
make his muscles soft and weak but
whatever no one in the movies travels
through space like it would actually
happen in real life except in For All
Mankind the best show on TV and finally
will t'challa's son become a young
Avenger if you're a friend of this
channel you know that we talk about the
Young Avengers a lot they have been set
up in multiple shows like one division
Falcon the Winter Soldier Hawkeye Loki
Multiverse of Madness Ms Marvel Ms
Marvel quantumania you get it and in the
comics in an alternate universe t'challa
did have a son named Azari who also was
a teen Avenger but for the MCU I'm gonna
say no his son has no powers he's in
grade school and if he is in the next
movie I think it would be as more of a
political tool but we want to know what
you think of all this let us know in the
comments below or at me on Twitter and
if it's your first time here please
subscribe or smash that Bell for alerts
for screen Crush I'm Ryan Erie Ryan Airy
you're the man well done the man Ryan
Hood oh yeah it does answer some pretty
thought-provoking things thank you Ryan
Hey killing it as always and you're a
great person Ryan's great person I know
I know him well in real life he's a
great guy all right guys well thank you
so much for being here uh be sure to
subscribe leave a like and uh listen us
with a patreon
flev Doran flev now my man I I heard in
our live stream that you did not really
care for this movie all that much I'm
sorry that's soul crushing because you
know like we're sharing a Marvel video
because Marvel's always been your jam
and the thing that you always really
love the most so to hear that you don't
really love this movie it's the plot
hole I want answers
let you know but you have been a patron
of Archer 35 months it would appear so
honestly and I'm looking at your profile
pic now you have this great hybrid of
like real rejects logo and site combined
because you love watching psych with
John or patreon so I want to say thank
you for being like this look at this
extra teal see you give as a supporter
even include a real rejects logo as part
of your profile pick it is so nice to
have someone like you at our page even
if we don't see eye to eye on certain
things I want you to know always respect
your opinion always respect you as a
person so much love to you brother
because you're not you're an amazing guy
I really really we both really
appreciate your support immensely love
you buddy
[Music]